lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
calcular a mano el coeficiente de
correlación para un conjunto de datos
variados y cuando digo y variados es
simplemente una forma elegante de decir
que para cada x que tengamos en un punto
que representa un dato voy a tener su
correspondiente y en ese mismo punto
bien ahora antes de que calculemos este
coeficiente de correlación déjame ver
que estemos completamente seguros de que
entendemos esta otra información
estadística que nos dan
así que si suponemos que estas son las
muestras que nos dan de una población
más amplia cada una con sus
correspondientes xy james entonces por
aquí tenemos la media muestral para x y
la desviación estándar muestral también
para x ahora viene la media muestral
para x fue muy fácil de calcular fue
simplemente 1 + 2 más 2 + 3 todo esto
sobre 4 lo cual es 8 sobre 4 que es
simplemente 2
borremos esto y ahora la desviación
estándar muestral como ya hemos visto
antes la encontramos con la raíz
cuadrada de la suma de las distancias de
cada uno de estos puntos a la media
muestral al cuadrado ya su vez todo eso
dividido entre el número de datos menos
uno lo cual va a ser bueno uno menos dos
al cuadrado más dos menos dos al
cuadrado donde 12 es este número de aquí
más dos menos dos al cuadrado otra vez
se repiten más 3 - 2 al cuadrado ya todo
esto hay que dividirlo entre el número
de datos que como hablamos de la
desviación estándar muestral tenemos
cuatro puntos y serán 41 lo que nos da 3
ahora lo bueno es que esto se simplifica
bastante bien porque este 0 este 0 este
de aquí es 1 y este también es uno por
lo que esencialmente nos quedamos con la
raíz cuadrada de dos tercios que es
aproximadamente cero punto 816 así que
de lujo de aquí sale esto ahora tenemos
lo mismo para la media muestral para
james es la suma de 12 36 estos dividido
entre 4 lo cual es simplemente 3 y
también tenemos una desviación estándar
muestral para ello la cual podemos
calcular de la misma manera que para x y
en este caso vamos a obtener
aproximadamente 2.160 bien ahora con
todo esto vamos a pensar en cómo
calcular el coeficiente de correlación
así que por aquí voy a poner la
representación o la fórmula para
calcular el coeficiente de correlación y
tal vez en un principio parezca un poco
intimidante pero realmente lo único que
está diciendo es para cada valor de x y
encontraremos el puntaje z para x z de x
esto para cada x en particular entonces
déjame ponerlo
x in y podemos decir que está de acá es
el puntaje z para cada quien particular
z y el subíndice y ahora lo que esto me
está diciendo es mira para cada dato x
que tengamos encuentra la diferencia
entre él y la media muestral y esa
diferencia divide la entre la desviación
estándar muestral o es lo mismo que
decir cuántas desviaciones estándar
muestrales tenemos de la diferencia de
un valor particular de xy la media
muestral así que esto es lo que
representa el puntaje z para cada dato x
y por acá tenemos lo mismo para allá el
puntaje z para cada dato james es
cuántas desviaciones estándar muestrales
tenemos de la diferencia de un valor
particular jeff y la media muestral y
vamos a sumar todas estas y lo vamos a
dividir entre el número de datos menos
uno ahora en el mundo real no vamos a
tener sólo cuatro puntos podemos tener
muchos más pero esto lo haría muy pesado
de calcular a mano
qué bueno comúnmente usamos algún
programa de computadora que nos ayuden a
resolver este tipo de ejercicios pero en
esta ocasión lo vamos a hacer paso por
paso así que bueno en esta situación
particular
efe va a ser igual a 1 / n 1 que como
tenemos cuatro pares de datos entonces
será un tercio por la suma de los
productos de los puntajes z así que en
el primer par que tenemos aquí me va a
dar los siguientes puntajes z observa el
primer puntaje z para x1 va a ser igual
a bueno tengo uno menos 2 es decir qué
tan lejos estamos de la media muestral
entre la desviación estándar muestral
que eran 0 punto 816 bien ya esto hay
que multiplicarlo y ahora vamos a
fijarnos en la variable ya tengo la
distancia entre la variable james y la
media muestral lo cual va a ser 1 menos
tres entre la desviación estándar
muestral en tiempo que eran 2.160
y ahora nos vamos a mantener haciendo
esto varias veces así que vamos a ver el
siguiente el siguiente es 22 entre 0.8
116 es decir que este 2 le estoy
quitando la media muestral en x bien y
bueno todo esto lo voy a multiplicar por
y ahora vamos a fijarnos en este 2 en
este 12 10 menos 3 entre 2.160 ya esto
le vamos a sumar y bueno está muy bien
que tenemos solo cuatro datos así que
vamos al tercero tengo otra vez 22 menos
2 entre 0.8 116 x y ahora tengo este 3
menos 3 que también es la media muestral
en que entre 2.160
el último par que es bueno tengo 3 - 2
entre 0.8 cientos 16 ya esto
multiplicado por 6 menos tres entre
2.160
bien ahora antes de traer la calculadora
por acá vamos a ver si tenemos algunas
simplificaciones porque por ejemplo aquí
tengo 2 - 2 esto va a ser cero y cero
por lo que sea es cero entonces todo
esto se va y por acá tengo también dos
menos dos y tres menos tres lo cual
también se va ya que arriba tengo uno
menos dos lo cual es menos uno y uno
menos tres lo cual es menos dos entonces
vamos a escribir lo tengo que r va a ser
igual a un tercio que multiplica a bueno
menos uno por menos 2 2
entonces me va a quedar 2 entre 0.8 116
por 2.160 ya esto le tengo que sumar 32
que es 16 menos 33
entonces me queda 1 por 3 estrés entre
lo mismo 0.8 116 por 2.160 y ahora
observa como tenemos el mismo
denominador ojo tengo 2 entre esta cosa
más 3 entre esa misma cosa bueno eso va
a ser igual a 5 entre esa misma cosa así
que puedo escribirlo todo en una
presión como 5 entre 0.8 116 por 2.160 y
ahora si es momento de traer la
calculadora para came para obtener este
resultado así que déjenme escribirlo
un tercio esto que va a multiplicar a 5
entre
0.8 116 por 2.160 ok esto va a ser igual
y observa obtenemos 0.900 46 redondeado
a milésimas entonces eres
aproximadamente 0 punto 946 dejame
escribirlo r es aproximadamente 0 punto
946 bien así que que nos dice esto bueno
el coeficiente de correlación es la
medida que nos dice que también puede
describir una recta
la relación entre xy y even siempre va a
ser mayor o igual a menos 1 y menor o
igual a 1
si fuera igual a 1 entonces eso
significa que tenemos una recta con
pendiente positiva que completamente
puede describir esta relación y si ere
fuera menos 1 entonces eso significaría
que tenemos una recta con pendiente
negativa que completamente puede
describir esta relación y una r entre
estos dos valores lo que nos indica es
que también los describe claro si eres
igual a cero entonces la recta no
describe en nada la relación entre x y
ahora regresando a nuestro caso
particular nuestra r es muy cercana a 1
lo que significa que en la recta
describe la relación de una manera muy
adecuada así que por ejemplo estoy
intentando hacer un dibujo a mano de la
recta que pasa por la media muestral de
x y d elía es decir que pasa por el
punto 23 esto lo vamos a aprender con
más detalle en el siguiente vídeo y de
bueno si la pongo por aquí creo que esta
parece una muy buena recta
ahora observa que es una recta que
describe bastante bien la relación entre
xy de todos los puntos no es perfecta
porque en ese caso tendremos una red de
1 pero es una aproximación bastante
buena para describir qué está pasando en
esta gráfica ahora la siguiente cosa que
quiero hacer es que nos enfoquemos en la
intuición que es lo que está pasando con
estos puntajes z y cómo es que el
producto de los puntajes z
correspondientes nos dan esta propiedad
de la que acabamos de hablar es decir
donde era igual a 1 te da una fuerte
correlación positiva y donde era igual a
menos 1 te da una fuerte correlación
negativa bueno vamos a dibujar por aquí
la media muestral esto para x que ya
sabemos que es igual a 2 entonces déjame
dibujarla por aquí este es el eje x de
aquí tenemos todos los valores que
podemos tomar en x igualados y para ello
sabemos que es de 3 así que voy a hacer
lo mismo este es el eje 10 y aquí
tenemos la recta y igual a 3
ahora podemos dibujar también las
desviaciones estándar muestrales veamos
la desviación estándar muestral para x
es de 0.8 cientos 16 aproximadamente así
que si me aproximo y tomo 0.8 116 menos
que la media voy a obtener algún lugar
por aquí así que esta es la desviación
estándar muestral debajo de la media
muestral y ahora vamos a hacer una
desviación estándar muestral por encima
de la media muestral lo cual me va a dar
algo por aquí un lugar que va a pasar
por aquí y si hago lo mismo para ayer
bueno la desviación estándar muestral
por encima de la media muestral me dan
bueno observar 3 2.160 es como 5.160 y
la desviación estándar muestral por
debajo de la media muestral me da algo
como un 3 menos 2 es 11 menos 0.160 es
como 0.8 cientos 40 es decir algún lugar
de por aquí bien así que por ejemplo
para este par 1,1 que es lo que estamos
haciendo ok lo que estamos diciendo
a cuántas desviaciones estándar
muestrales estamos de la media muestral
y eso es menos 1 entre 0.8 116 que es lo
que tenemos aquí y calculamos por acá y
después nos preguntamos a cuantas
desviaciones estándar muestrales estamos
en dirección
jeff de la media muestral en ese punto
lo cual nos da menos 2 entre 2.160 y ojo
aunque ambas son negativas las dos
contribuyen para obtener
al final obtenemos un valor positivo al
multiplicar las y la forma de pensarlo
es que esto nos ayuda a acercarnos un
poquito más a uno esto sí ambos tienen
un puntaje z negativo eso quiere decir
que aún así tenemos una correlación
positiva entre las variables ahora si
nos fijamos en otro punto que nos dan
como dato este el 22 bueno
la variable x va a estar justo en la
media y es por eso que todo el término
se vuelve a cero se elimina el puntaje z
es cero y ojo esto no contribuye a
nuestra r
entonces nos aleja un poco de uno
la razón del por qué nos aleja un poco
de uno aunque no sea negativo es porque
no está contribuyendo la suma y de todas
maneras se dividen entre este valor n 1
que incluye a este par de datos 2 2 y si
tuvieras un punto donde x estuviera por
debajo de la media y estuviera por
arriba de la media bueno en este caso
tendremos que sumar algo negativo porque
el puntaje z de ye sería positivo y el
puntaje zeta de x sería negativo y ahora
cuando lo ponemos en la suma en ese caso
lo que estaríamos haciendo es quitarle o
restarle a la suma lo que haría que el
resultado de r fuera menor y de manera
similar pasa en este caso donde x se
encuentra por arriba de la media y jeff
por debajo de ella lo que nos daría el
producto de algo positivo por algo
negativo y entonces el resultado de r
sería menor bien hasta aquí dejemos este
vídeo y continuamos en el siguiente